that road rage incident marks the 112th
traffic related death in metro's
jurisdiction since the beginning of the
year and that's just one of the reasons
why the traffic traffic safety summit is
held annually to find new ways to
protect drivers and pedestrians the
alcoholmate joining us now live from
palace station where that event will be
held later this afternoon or later this
morning i should say bianca
[Music]
hey good morning heather good morning
john so total lives lost this year is up
30 percent and that's way too many lives
lost on our roadways across nevada and
again that's why indot and public safety
officials are going to be meeting here
at palace station later on this morning
to discuss ways to keep people safe
while driving of course also pedestrians
so the top two reasons for more than 280
deaths this year are impairment and in
speeding and that's across the state of
nevada indot law enforcement and other
safety partners want to know why this
continues to happen and how to prevent
it during this year's summit leaders
will participate in traffic incident
management first responder training
exercises they'll discuss child
passenger safety also young driver and
pedestrian safety as well as figure out
how to reduce risky and impaired driving
so the summit will start later on this
morning it wraps up tomorrow and of
course we'll have an update for you at
noon bianca holman live local now